This brings me to really
I think probably the most
important story for me
that I have ever worked on.
Which was a story about
Charles Darwin.
The story was called
"Was Darwin wrong?"
And then in the magazine
it said "No."
You know, 'cause essentially
everything he said
is true and correct.
And, so we did this
article on Darwin.
And these are the birds that
he collected in the Galapagos.
And that's one of the privileges
of being a
Geographic photographer.
You call up the British
Museum and you know
most of the time
they'll say "Yes".
If you want to-- I want to
see this or this
and they'll let you do it,
if you pay them.
So these are birds that Darwin
collected in the Galapagos
which helped him
found his theory
because the beaks are
different sizes
even though they are
the same species.
This is essentially an example
of island bio-evolution
which for the story that
we did for the magazine
you know, everybody
would have expected
you to go to the Galapagos but
Todd James, photo editor decided
that we shouldn't and I agreed.
But this was a really
difficult story to work on.
We were in Jamaica,
the Dominican Republic
and Puerto Rico shooting
these different anoles
which are the same species
but have evolved separately
and differently.
We made comparative
photos between
gorilla hands and a
human skeletal hand.
This is a naked mole rat,
which is an amazing story.
A 100 years before
one was found
Darwin predicted
that there would be
a mammal that had
hive-like behavior.
And in the horn of Africa
they found these animals.
This is a
26-year old individual.
She's a queen and has bred
thousands of offspring.
And the interesting thing
about this is that
these stories always come back
to where I learn something.
or I reapply something
I've learned.
But the researcher
on this told me that
there is all this research
going on about, you know
how they don't get certain
kinds of diseases.
And the naked mole rats
don't get cancer.
So, this is going to be...
it's holding good promise for
research in different areas.
And this was actually
Darwin's beetle collection
which was great because that's
how Darwin became interested
in the natural world was because
he was a beetle collector
as a kid.
Then we come to
Alfred Russel Wallace.
He's a naturalist, much
younger than Darwin.
He wasn't from a wealthy
family like Darwin
and he became a commercial
Victorian collector
who would go to different
parts of the world
and send back
specimens for people.
This is pre-television,
pre-film, pre-magazines.
So, people would have,
you know,
cassowaries stuffed
in their parlor
that they could
talk about.
So it was a form of just
decoration and entertainment.
He had an idea, he wrote Darwin
a letter, and mailed it to him.
Darwin gets this letter
and then he doesn't do
anything for two weeks.
It's called "Darwin's Pause".
And, he's floored
because Wallace
has the same idea as him.
Essentially the exact same
idea that he has about
the thing that makes evolution
work is natural selection.
So, he didn't do anything for
two weeks, then he announces
the Theory of Evolution
via natural selection.
And he, it's...
the theory is by Charles Darwin
and Alfred Russel Wallace.
Darwin had been working
on this for 25 years
since he got off the Beagle
and he may have not published
it until he passed away
because his family
was religious.
At least his wife's family was.
But I think he was
forced to publish
because of Wallace's paper.
We also were able to go
to a tuberculosis prison,
a multi-drug resistant
tuberculosis prison,
where it was developed
accidentally in Siberia.
We used this in the story as
an example of survival
of the fittest,
which is a really well-known
concept of evolution.
What happened was the
authorities in this prison
didn't use enough antibiotics.
They used enough to contain
it but the germs evolved
and changed and became
immune to the antibiotics.
They've actually found traces
of this kind of tuberculosis
in Brighton Beach,
in Long Island.
You know, we were working
on it like crazy.
We had to get TB tests
before we went
and after we came back.
This was a wonderful
opportunity for me because
it was a big story,
I think it was 48 pages
and it was just that the topic
became so interesting to me
that we travelled for 58 days to
I think, 12 different countries
and 26 different locations.
And we were doing
it on four-by-five film
so it was a really challenging,
challenging assignment.
And it was three weeks
before my wedding, so...
Thank you very much.
( applause )